I worked with two geniuses in my life
what was Charlie Chaplin the other one
is sitting next to me
Jonathan wins and I was not the first
choice for this part a Jackie Mason was
signed for this part
and he gave mr. Cramer his nightclub
schedule and Kramer fired him and they
needed somebody in a hurry and my agent
sent me the script and I said you know I
almost got killed reading the script I
read like the Manhattan phone book and I
said you don't expect me to do all these
stunts get thrown through a plain glass
window well I
Myers my agent was buying in Michigan
and he said Marvin your deal is that you
can do all the stunts that your partner
can do and I said who's my partner and
he said Arnold Stang and I said Arnold's
the biggest coward the American theater
and if he consents to do a stunt
I'll consent to but we there was a
stickler in it
we didn't know we had at work with the
next marine named Jonathan winters who
wanted us all to do our own stunts so we
sat on the sidelines hoping that
Jonathan would get hurt not seriously
hurt just a little bit so he'd need a
stunt man and sure enough it in
rehearsal he sprained his back and I'm
and a lot older than I looked at each
other we knew we'd have to have stuntmen
as well well it's hard to find a
stuntman for Arnold Stang he he was
about five foot two and they finally got
somebody who did Kemp's
and his name was Janos Prohaska now
Janos was much more at home climbing
trees and that he was in regular life
but the problem is that Arnold had a
very small chin and no shoulders and his
stuntman had you Childers so they had a
buildup Arnold shoulders so he looked as
good as his stuntman I got a stuntman
named Bill Maxwell a very handsome kid
but thin and so they put my glasses on
him and he walked into a tree they kept
putting padding in him so hot because I
was fat and they wanted to meet him to
look fat and I kept taking it atlas I
wanted to look thin
there was a wonderful wonderful great
show and it's become part of history
Marcia I never thought I would ever
achieve that but it's it's about greed
and now Reid is a national pastime